welcome to this video playing we won we
won from the US and probably an Enzo
let's play something else I am mostly
playing Rubinstein and ZEB variation
this line usually taught expire offline
other nims Oh twins Indian hybrid it's
also very interesting yeah 92 is some a
move that only got popular the last 10
to 15 years the point is that after the
the former main line 63 very often black
later played III f380 for and with
playing 92 first he tries to get in this
with one move and I was successful with
this getting saving a move and this is
not the end of the world but it's still
an accomplishment yeah we get this
blocked position type very typical this
is a mistake g5 very often it's a normal
move but it's a mistake in this
particular position because i get to f5
really quickly while let's say is forced
to do things that that he doesn't really
want to do this is in fact interesting
Nigel 7ss idea this is some wire play
age for quickly he wants to play Knight
g7 to 22 carbon f5 the 93 this also
covers g2
yeah here we go ok to take here you can
take G to actually interesting if he
takes on g tool yeah but it's still an
excellent position if I take mmm I don't
need to I don't really need to do this
this is also just simple and good ok
let's let's pledge you for attending to
take on g5 conveniently
you are activating this bishop maybe you
can play with h8s would have been
interesting
hmm it's very closed I mean it looks
like looks nice but it's not not so
clear how to get anything substantial
here
yeah may I feel very very well defended
looked like problematic position and
maybe maybe in the zone tending to
capture with the vision
the a long problem of this position is
that maybe it can well not maybe can
exchange the light on f5 and without a
night it's difficult to make progress
the bishops are nice but the position
this is very closed very difficult to to
to make any headway
we takes Bishop takes you know I
threatened 27 at least but yeah wants
not substantial threat Queenie aids may
be something you can do I'll wait if i
take now on age 8 and take a seven ok
maybe I can't a playbook age 21 ok maybe
maybe to threaten this threaten group h
eight and queen is have now and if he
takes rook takes or you just ignores
this okay then I'll do that think the
searches to win I mean okay simply fail
to to like that resilience that was very
simple but effective it probably needs
to take on h1 or Queenie eight create
this also possible I think I think I had
a really good position here but I didn't
really make so much out of it Bishop
everyone is the best move yes yeah okay
this is much much better yeah hey this
is not terribly bad but this is just
better the app yeah and it is better
because the night on a form while
looking nice it's not attacking anything
and I'm threatening just to play G 396
night h6 this is a very strong threat
actually
I don't really don't even see him let's
say place any move yeah this is even
gaining a tempo and resins basically
yeah this is very strong you should have
one well and miss that I mean this is
this is certainly a nice for white but
it's not something something to to be am
thrilled about very difficult to make
any headway you know and now just
Queenie 8 and I think like is perfectly
all right I don't I don't think I should
exchange Queens this would happen maybe
a move like that keep giving me this
additional idea but let's say so let's
say just something like that it's a it's
probably probably in about equal I have
the worst structure let's say something
like that and i'm going to take on f4
know something like that like the
blackest is okay yeah but is he's lot
better in her by any means but this this
just gives it gives it a completely away
probably even a mate yeah the computer
gives them made already in a tenuous or
something alright thanks
watching